hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast
what's going on how I yeah I am once
again this is like all of a sudden I
never have [ __ ] guests and then all
of a sudden they all come out of the
woodwork almost at the same time on all
musicians and once again we have a very
special guest mr. Wilkenfeld how are you
I'm good
you got a new album coming out yep right
just glad you know what it is I didn't
want to start with that because I know
you [ __ ] been talking about all kinds
of music I had to ask you cuz we're over
your place right now well how you liking
the Vitamix
I love the Vitamix cuz I gotten into
like I'm an old man now I don't know if
you can tell I use a lot of lotion I
think I'm still in my 20s but I'm but to
turn 51 here in June and I've started to
do like for breakfast I like to just
have like a smoothie yeah as phony as
that sounds to everybody doesn't live in
it's the [ __ ] greatest thing ever
right you just drink it you're full yeah
you know rather than doing the Denny's
Grand Slam breakfast you feel like a tub
of [ __ ] which makes you eat something
else bad so people been telling me about
the Vitamix my life right now I'm like
like that was a thing you have all these
amazing instruments and [ __ ] and then
thing that stuck I was like oh a Vitamix
I wonder if that one Masha's up the
[ __ ] spinach and kale a little bit
better I have the best recipe - you do
yeah I got two really good ones that I
stand by they trade I got one that I
substitute the kale for spinach spinach
tastes better all it is it's just that
substitute for dandelion greens just FYI
you Swift I use dandelion greens now
what do you do to sweeten that up so
it's not bitter as [ __ ] I use some honey
just a little bit just a little bit yeah
know what time my wife took me to some
restaurant we ended up eating like
dandelions like a dandelion we both
trying it out like hey man let's be
healthy we both looked at each other
it's like it was one of the worst things
I ever tasted
so when you grind that up we have almond
milk in there too or it's it's actually
a juice really it's not like a smoothie
but it's quite thick which is why I
still call it a smoothie but - dandelion
greens cilantro
a little bit of black pepper oh my god
tumeric ginger like fresh ginger which
would you call me okay what you stand by
that it's the song sing it sounds a
little bit of honey
what else do I put in there water
there's obviously water and and then I
get hungry an hour and a half later
where do you buy Danny's going your
backyard and yeah come out of the
[ __ ] grass what do you get you Daniel
it's like any health food store whole
food sir I never say I gotta be honest
with you no I've been to a few of those
little health food places I've never
I've never seen that but uh alright mine
mine is just simple it's just a almond
it's a almond milk with some almonds
just in case there's not enough almond
in there there's some spinach the [ __ ]
is a banana a little bit of ice I know
I'm forgetting something berries
blueberries no I got to get a couple
goes because I I basically have to go to
smoothies and I'm getting sick of them
and then I have like this Greek yogurt
parfait and I just sort of rotate that
on a three thin I'm just I've had it you
know you know like when you've been
jamming with people too long you're like
we need some new blood or something
that's where I am with mustn't me trying
to steer it back to the music here so
let's at least say the name of your
incredible album that I only heard three
tracks of cuz I couldn't figure out how
to download it for those of you not
familiar with Tala she's she's basically
played with everybody and I promised her
I wasn't gonna bring up all the past
like hey man what was it like playing
with this person but she's you know IMDB
or she's played with literally everybody
and you've basically been known as this
monster bass player that can just play
with anybody and your hidden talent of
an unbelievable singing voice is finally
displayed like that's what killed me
when I listened you just played those
three tracks for me aside from of course
how up front you know the basses and all
the mix which I'm lovin yeah I had no
idea you could sing like that I kind of
um I
I've kept it quiet for a while like I
started as a singer-songwriter when I
first picked up guitar mhm and then sort
of started focusing just on guitar when
I moved to America cuz I left home when
I was 16 right I moved to America and I
went to this music school for a little
while and I went from like only being
hope you went to a nice place all this
crap about the
Michael Jackson documentary which I
fused to [ __ ] watch why would you do
that why would you put although that
those horrible stories in your head it's
like I get it all right the guy was a
creep and now he's dead so what are we
doing I guess you got a list somebody's
going someone was telling me going you
have well you have to watch it so then
you you as a parent it's like I'm not
gonna let some [ __ ] guys sleep with
my kid behind nine doors anyway so you
got this album I went to this this
school and I went from being allowed to
play like half an hour a day to wanting
to practice for like six hours a day was
that torture for you considering the way
you took I remember you hearing yeah I
watched that interview you said the
first time you actually played a chord
you got emotional you cried yeah so you
love something that much and then all of
a sudden going to you going to school in
Australia yeah so they were teaching
about Columbus and all the great stuff
that happened here in America of course
right whatever it was how you guys you
got dropped off by the English convicts
apparently yeah exactly yeah exactly
so then all of a sudden was that torture
for you in school it was just it was
hard because you know academia was the
focus especially like where I like with
who I grew up with you know my mom just
like really wanted me to you know you
imagine yeah I do all my schoolwork and
stuff I mean she's probably just being a
responsible parent but like I just was
not into geography and history I was
into did you ever just like to pick up
the bass and be like mom listen to this
I mean listen to this and then look at
my grades in math and you tell me which
direction I'm supposed to go in I mean I
was just I was a guitarist at that point
like I only switched to bass when I was
17 which and I already moved to America
at that point but yeah I mean she heard
me play I just I think that like you
know the music business is a tough place
and she probably just thought like maybe
maybe that's not the best thing for you
to do to be in the music industry it's
so uncertain so but I wasn't gonna
listen to what anyone was going to say
like that's all I knew that
had to be a musician and I didn't care
if I was gonna be homeless and write and
be a musician I just I knew that that's
what I had to do so I never wonder how
many how many musicians are out there
because that story is like you had that
inner drive and like I always wondered
like how many like Jimi Hendrix they're
like working at Home Depot because their
parents or something you know they just
didn't have that thing to be like no no
no [ __ ] that I'm doing it right when
really important people that basically
taught you how to walk and talk and all
of that stuff start telling you you know
you shouldn't go in that direction is
that's just something that you it was
that something that developed was it the
love that you had when you started
playing guitar that you were like no I
literally have to do this or do you feel
you always had sort of that that that
Drive well I actually think as a kid
especially as a teenager like if your
parents tell you not to do something
you're gonna want to do it more like 99%
of teenagers I'd read those days so it
probably worked out in the the right way
that she didn't really want me to focus
on music because that just made me want
to do it more oh okay yeah I mean I'm
kind of I mean I wouldn't even say I was
necessarily rebellious but if you want
something that bad and someone's telling
you know you're like well I'll prove to
you that I really deserve this and I'm
gonna work my ass off and I did like I
was so focused like my rebellion as a
teenager was to succeed as a musician it
wasn't like to go off and do drugs or
whatever else like that was my rebellion
was was success you know I went to I was
looking at schools to see which one to
take you know put my daughter and you
know all the public schools a [ __ ] out
here I guess so you gotta sent him to
private school and spend like a zillion
dollars by the time they're like eight
it's so [ __ ] stupid
so he went to this one and it was like a
french-speaking one right so all the
kids was amazing the kids were super
smart is a great school and and but the
lady given like the tour right she goes
the hell did she say I asked her I said
hey
you know did the parents kind of learn
French along the way she's like no we
encourage you to speaks a perfect
English
at home and blah blah I thought what if
I want to learn to and she looked at me
she goes yes it's too late for you it's
just like goddamn I actually respected
it but you know what I'm so happy she
said that to me because now I got this
thing like I and I'll show you
yeah and I got flashcards over to
flashcards and I'm like looking at I'm
trying to put together phrases and stuff
I you know listen the back of my head I
know she's probably right and I love
this goal that I'm actually excited that
the potential to go there but like I I
do relate to that as far as when
somebody says that but there was a
period in my life where I wasn't that
guy oh yeah like if somebody said that
to me I'd be like oh okay forget it oh
really
so I think I've probably had that since
I was really young like like just
determination to do whatever I want to
do cuz like I remember being super
focused on running before I was a guitar
player and I was like obsessed with
long-distance running like and and in my
head I'm like I have to be the best I
have to be the best runner goals one
girl that was better than me and and it
pissed me off so much and I remember
like there was this one race that was I
don't know it's like a ten mile race it
was really long and and I just I just
had to beat this girl and I did beat the
girl who did but I did this like like
celebratory dance afterwards because I
was so excited and I threw my back out
so then I I kind of was like humbling
around for a little while and couldn't
run like a couple weeks and then that's
actually when I walked past that guitar
and started playing i'm een i don't
think she saw it she was that far behind
me wow that's like a feel-good movie
except dated they always run krytus
before you blow out your back then you
became like your musician so you know
the few tracks that I heard in that
three the three that I listened to is
definitely you know this is really like
a very personal album as far as like you
know talking about yourself that one you
just play what was the name of the
haunted heart wanted loved haunted loved
the one that's just the basin voice the
orchestra yeah yeah that was some pretty
heavy lyrics that made me start thinking
about my parents
I went on a little trip there well yeah
yeah thinking about my whole life and I
people listening here I can't recommend
like the level of quality of the music
that you you've done with other people
and now to actually hear hey these are
my ideas with your voice on top of it
the second I heard a few of these I was
like oh this is one of these these
albums I'm just gonna put in back in
that day when you had a CD just stick it
in there until the thing just started
skipping on it what you mean how your
iTunes is skipping on you right now 30
second I know I know you can download it
you gots modifies I don't have Spotify I
I'm this idiot who I still buy music and
then it fills up your computer and now
because right now I need a new I need a
new laptop I need a new phone and I know
I put iPad the whole thing [ __ ] the
bed on me at the same time and yeah I
miss can I buy it on vinyl I have a
record player
I already got me a burrito here from
coming over so I'll I'll throw some
money at towards that but wasn't gonna
say so you also mentioned that you're
actually gonna be doing a whole tour in
this thing too huh yeah now a headlining
tour you open him what he had on
headlining headlining nice I'm excited
it's just your first like big headlining
tour cuz you've always been like the
hired gun as far as I know yeah this is
your first like well I I actually I was
opening for the WHO with my band and we
played the Boston Garden and something
really cool is it called the Boston
Garden they called the TD Banknorth
Garden key how'd you like that that was
fun
didn't you do that recently yeah I did
some stand-up there yeah and I did jam
before with my brother so cool we had a
good we definitely had your you know so
funny zoo yeah ever no one was paying
attention at all when we were playing or
whatever they thought it's kind of funny
that we're doing it and this is comedian
Jim Breuer who does this amazing bid on
Slayer fans like how dedicated and crazy
they are well we actually played I think
it's only play we played a Slayer song
and literally this it was like no one
was reacting to anything we were doing
we sucked right the second we started
playing Slayer some [ __ ] security
guide like you know halfway if the arena
just goes
hilarious so now your style of music
like going no you can ask me something I
was gonna say like like what does
playing before a stand-up set do for you
it makes the venue not as intimidating
I've only done it it like why why it is
because you know it stand up in a place
that big doesn't make sense you like
honey you know I I had all these
feelings of like why am I like how did I
get here what am I doing here what the
[ __ ] do I have to say that justifies all
these people showing up you know then
normal if you're any sort of like human
being that's what you have if you're a
psychopath you just like how come we're
not playing were playing the Roman
Colosseum but I was sitting there and
that's what that what was what was going
through my head but the first time I
ever did one I did for the New York
Comedy Festival and I did Madison Square
Garden and we got together and jammed in
there and I just did that because I
loved Led Zeppelin and they did song
remains the same if I could just play
some drums there and make a little bit
of noise and what happened was we were
having so much fun and I invited so many
people down there they like you know I
didn't ever fully forget where I was but
next thing you know you know I was
yelling hey Josh is that that Motley
Crue thing and you just yelling and you
just kind of made it yours yeah so that
night it just didn't it didn't feel I
was able to kind of just like I had
already made a bunch of noise in there
and nothing bad happened you know I
didn't know the roof didn't collapse so
I think that that's kind of like what it
did for me although I [ __ ] up at the
forum because I played it like three
hours I almost walked up cuz I was just
like I got off stage and I was like
wiped out I was just like oh I know
oh no but then like the Adrenaline's
like oh my god what if I vomit from all
these [ __ ] people you know that
that'll get you through a good 90-minute
why do you not like play on stage for
your audience because I respect them no
you say that I'm good for a comedian
I'll give you that but I am NOT a you
know what I like
like one of my favorite things to do is
to watch a pro play mm-hmm because it's
just you know when they're just doing
like a soundcheck a lot of times they'll
be physically playing something that I
could play but I could never make it
sound like that and there's always like
a personnel you know if you listen to a
really good drummer you can hear like
you can hear them in the playing which
you know took me a while to be able to
hear that but now I'm able to do and
I've seen I don't know there's just
something cool about it it's like
watching a professional hockey player
like taping up their stick there's just
something that when you see a pro doing
something it's in you're into it
especially if it's your hobby it's
[ __ ] mesmerizing so that's that's why
when a few times I've come over here
like I'm always in there because I like
sitting back and just watching all you
guys play and my favorite thing about
watching a live band is watching a band
that doesn't play it the same way every
night and even if you've never seen the
band you can tell because they're like
looking at each other and everything so
that's when I get into like oh man
they're in the moment right now this is
like watching a comic Griff and
somebody's gonna do something make
somebody's smile and then they add
something else and I mean just as an
audience member and a fan of music
trying to pick up like that thing going
on and like my intern like I'm the
band's I listened to growing up like I
remember Stevie Ray Vaughan whenever he
was playing a solo it was like Chris
Layton and Tommy Shannon and Reese we're
always looking right at him like is he
gonna go back in again oh we go we're
going back to you know him singing and
he just would [ __ ] be wailing it and
he had this little thing you just look
at him he gives give him a little nod
and how they all were like okay and and
and they wouldn't [ __ ] that up I'm just
having attempted to do you know get
together with friends and play and
everything I just I have such an
admiration for it so I mean that's how I
feel about comedy and great comedy and
that's why I like watching you perform
oh yeah when I do a great [ __ ] joke and
I'm not open to somebody who just did a
dick joke damn it amazed
it's right on the same level no but like
because I just started as you know like
getting it really heavily into comedy
the past like a year or so yeah and like
the reason that appeals to me so much is
because it like speaks to both parts of
me as a musician there's the the jazz
musician in me which is like the
improvisational musician which like like
really enjoys watching you riff like and
I'm just
and then there's lash bomb then there's
like the composer like the the person
that's like you know into writing songs
and like and then watching you create
this amazing material planets
it's very sad it's not a requirement for
people in your band because I mean when
you like when you go and do this tour
like I I just know doing the same jokes
over and over and over again it's like
you have to like yeah do something to
break out of it do you on this tour I
mean you sell any album you got to go
out and and and you know play it and
sell the music to them like how how much
like messing around do you do I do a lot
and then is a requirement and that's why
it's been really tricky to find band
members and I have found like the
perfect guitarist and drummer to play
with me because you know my music is
compositionally like lyrically for
instance very influenced by folk music
or songwriter music but then musically
it's it's influenced from anything from
rock to folk to jazz to whatever it just
goes all over the place that's what I
was loving but this this some sort of
through line maybe it's you I don't know
what it is on and because I was just
listening to dance sounded so great and
then I I really started listening to the
mix of it I'm like wow she's the whole
bottom end of this song and then it fell
I don't I would say technically but I
felt like the guitars and keys were like
up here yeah and but you were the sort
of the meat and potatoes of the whole
thing driving the whole song but like
the the different tones and stuff there
was why I'm unforced I don't know in the
names of the corner painter the fella
yeah when I went into that bridge it was
out so it's sections called that middle
sections just like what the [ __ ] is that
and then you go right
back to that part that really rocks oh
yeah I looked at you I was just like
that's when the crowds gonna go nuts
cuz you taking him on this ride where
you coming out and you just you know
blowing their wig back in the beginning
and then it goes to this other places
like whoa what the [ __ ] is this this is
this mood thing well that's what it's
like a people start taking their drugs
in the crowd I would feel that was a
time all sudden somebody sparked up a
[ __ ] J's we used to say and and then
all of a sudden like I don't know what
you just punch him in the face again and
then the [ __ ] song is over it's just
like yeah I think that the cohesiveness
on the record comes from like having the
same band play all of these songs even
though they're they're very different
like some are you know just vocal and
bass and some are acoustic guitar and
and very little behind me and then
there's like these full rockers but it's
the same band and I just think that
that's really important like first how
longs it take you to put that together
well it took me a few years to sort of
search for the sound of the record right
and like figure out who was gonna play
on it and who like what was the the best
sound for these songs and then I finally
went into the studio with Blake Mills
and Jeremy and Paul Stacey and we cut
corner painter which is the first song I
played Eunice the first song on the
record and that when I heard that back
on the speakers and this was no bass it
was just I was playing acoustic baritone
guitar Blake was playing guitar and
Jeremy was playing drums and the sound
was so full well I think I didn't even
want to play bass on it
there's no bass on that song at all I
just played it on an organ and then
Benmont Tench overdubbed organ as well
like a pump organ mm-hmm but I heard
that song was like this is the lynchpin
for the record and so then I went home
and I like wrote a bunch of other songs
that I felt would fit with that vibe or
complement it and and then once I'd done
that we went back in the studio for it
was like anywhere from like 8 to 10 days
and cut the whole thing at once Wow and
so I think that that's part of the the
cohesiveness is that we just we cut it
all together hey when you put together a
band if you
had been like okay I know these two
people are right and then a third person
comes in and so takes it into another
direction you got to fire one of those
other two people there just because but
the other cuz the other person's such a
beast I mean it's a it's all about
cannot aside pointed at the drums when I
said like casting for a movie to like
sometimes it's the most important thing
is the casting all right how do you like
LA by the way miss Australia I don't
miss Australia some of my best friends
are there I had definitely missed them
you know but and I miss the beach I
don't really think that the beach in LA
is that cool no I got me I'm terrified
of the ocean and but every time I go to
Australia it's like oh if I was ever you
know there's a place to get eaten by a
shark it is definitely the coast of your
country it's so beautiful I was you know
at least you die beautifully yeah I I
remember we were there and like I don't
know when we were it was your your weird
winter down there which is just a
different time and it was too it was too
cold and windy it's not weird it's just
weird to me because I'm in the northern
hemisphere but so we were down there and
I was expecting it to be [ __ ] hot and
all of a sudden was like freezin and but
even then I was looking at I was like if
it wasn't so rough and it wasn't so cold
I think I would and maybe I did actually
go into the water when I was in Perth
because I just wanted to say that I
stood in the Indian Ocean and I
literally went up to my ankles and I got
back in and then I got in the car and I
was listening to the radio and there was
a helicopter following it like an 18
foot tiger shark along the beach just to
let the surfers and everybody know that
the thing was there and you guys had the
creepiest terminology ever for when
someone gets eaten by a shark you say he
was taken that's what I heard oh yeah
yeah it was some low light taking I'm
like oh my god I'd rather be eaten than
taken eating to me is it's over I mean
it's [ __ ] horrific and then I you
bleed out and it's overtaking means I
you took me somewhere I just start
thinking a Chain Saw Massacre when that
[ __ ] guy just grabbed that woman and
yanked her and slam the door taking
almost down slightly more polite though
now you can know
I guess what the next word is taken to
the movies right exactly
[Laughter]
taken to the movies shox
oh yeah I was gonna say you know it
seems you know what I liked it's this
fair play on this album yeah as far as
there was a few where it was the other
person and that was a few there was you
right so that's a that's a that's an
important milestone in your life when
you at least for me it was when I was
able to be like I you know I was going
through chicks of [ __ ] psychos you
know I did that tall I was about 35 and
I was just like I fell you know at what
point are you gonna [ __ ] is it maybe
you maybe who you're picking maybe what
you're bringing to the table and then
once I was able to do that I didn't
finally ended up meeting Nia I that's
kind of why I called the album love
remains because love remains as in the
remnants of love like the aftermath of
her love gone bad
or love remains like love still exists
oh I thought you meant there was still
pieces of other relationships in you it
it's both it's like the remnants and
then love still you know continues
there's always love well this is theory
among my guy friends that women are able
to cry it out because you're allowed to
cry that you're able to get past [ __ ]
and then it's just like [ __ ] gone
where guys like hang on to [ __ ] I mean I
was reading this book on Bob Cousy he's
one of the great Celtics and Bill
Russell right one of the greatest
players of all time
and Bob koozies wife passed away and he
still has a picture on the wall and he
still talks to all I guess I didn't
break up so maybe it was that but like
you know I still always joke with my
wife going you know if I died within
three weeks she'd have all my clothes
down a good will maybe a DVD in the back
of a [ __ ] closet but she's like no I
would never do that but I just feel like
women are better at either how you're
wired and then I also think it's more
it's one of the great emotions crying
when the great healing emotions is not
acceptable
for guys and you just shut it off so not
only do not get to heal you actually
make yourself I think worse by [ __ ]
holding it in it's bad enough you know I
don't know it's it's a really weird
thing so that's it that's actually I
don't I don't know what the word is but
to hear you say that that you actually
some of it stays in there I don't know
that makes me feel not as [ __ ] up yeah
also like I feel like when when you're
in love or when you love someone like it
people often like projected outwards as
if it's the other person that's making
you in love whereas like love is
actually just always in you and that
that person is maybe igniting it or
showing you that it's there but it is
always there and knowing that keeps me
centered yeah it's it's it's that's not
something that you can it's hard to
remember that you know I would I would
say I don't know I'm actually literally
getting uncomfortable just even talking
about it it helps my was walled off for
a long [ __ ] time and then I had like
this massive amount of love in me and it
would just come out in these weird ways
like about like like animals being
abused or any sort of person being hurt
I could feel it but like if I was just
with somebody and we going to the movies
like I didn't even know what the [ __ ] to
do
I'd just be sitting there like this
[ __ ] robot like did you enjoy that
now we're getting on the subway and it
was just like and I was meeting people I
just I mean I I'm embarrassed that we're
the kind of person I was back in the day
as far as like trying to get through
stuff like that but how did you break
through that I met somebody I couldn't
break up with I would in my head
fantasize during tough times of breaking
up with my now wife and in my head we
were living in this place where there
was there was first place was an
elevator in the other place had stairs
and when she was going to get on the
elevator even in the fantasy of being
single again before the door closed I
would run out and go get her or when she
would walk down the stairs and all right
I come back and I couldn't I couldn't
even
and hey for years I did that and it
never dawned on me like I've always been
so [ __ ] like not in touched with like
hey Bill you know this is the 20,000th
[ __ ] signal like I used to ride
around had a paper route back in the day
and I used to ride around in the morning
and I had memorized comedy routines with
my favorite comedians and I would
fantasize that I was doing them in front
of the school and it didn't dawn on me
at that point they hate bill maybe you
want to be a comedian it didn't it was
just I had no connection to it
whatsoever huh
it was just me I think at that point it
was all about you know getting people to
like me so I wouldn't get the [ __ ]
kicked out of me or I wouldn't have to
deal with some you know you know you
know it was it was before all this
caring on social media is just like the
hope every day at school is just like am
I gonna get it today or how can I get it
off for me and get it on to the next
weakest kid it was a very weird I don't
know some of it was good but a lot of it
wasn't necessarily probably the way kids
should grow up now we're probably like
overly doing it I don't know you don't
made me feel good when you came when I
came into you place there and you were
like oh there's my phone oh my gosh you
have massive advi I also unfortunately
get phone anxiety which I hate lectures
oh you don't have it right yeah if I
don't have it I start to like feel like
oh [ __ ] where's the phone
or like if I don't look at it for for
too long I start to feel that and so I
have to work really hard at like
disciplining myself so that I can like
keep it away from me for a certain
amount of hours to be like creative and
productive because it's just like I feel
so sorry for like for kids they're like
teenagers right now like
just like so attached to their phones
and I see what it does to my brain
teenager I am that's brutal ya know it
like gives you the shortest attention
span it like everything's just immediate
and so I'm just so glad that like it
kind of came a little bit later you
realize we're like lab rats because
we're like sort of the first wave of
like well let's see what this does to
people I actually saw you know I went
and I got gas today and I saw this after
the burrito I know that's gonna be later
that's why this podcast will not be a
full hour whenever they you know it's
hitting me what the [ __ ] is on the
microphones that I hear that me nuts
piece of fuzz so I was still there say
this is the podcast people are used to
get them so I pulled up to get yeah I
was getting pumping gas and you know
this la couple pulls up la meaning
beautiful I'm not judging them like
they're [ __ ] they're [ __ ]
beautiful right so they pull up and the
guy gets out to pump the gas the woman's
driving the second she barely pressed
park you know immediately the phone and
was just sitting there and I was
watching her and I was just like that's
me that is literally me I do that when
I'm driving like a lot I know it's it's
it's yeah I called a friend up one time
this is maybe about three months ago I
was trying to do like an intense period
of writing and I said hey could you just
because I'm you know it takes I think
apparently 28 days to break a habit I
think could you come over for you know
of 28 days apparently like can I give
you my phone and then just go away and
then I'll meet you back here and I did
that for a few days and actually like
helped me like reprogram my cell yeah
yeah and like once you do that then it's
like ah you you feel like you can
finally relax it's weird this is
something that I learned going overseas
and I can't get texting or anybody this
is what happens if you don't text
anybody nobody texts you like I would
come back thinking oh my god I haven't
checked my text messages in 10 days I'm
gonna have 5 million [ __ ] texts and I
had like maybe six really seven yeah I
don't what am ia loser nobody like it's
like I don't text people you're like now
I come
özil Ian of them now I feel like an
[ __ ] no I came back and it's just
like you it's it's like you know like
once do you want something in your life
not to happen and you don't realize how
much of it you're creating yeah okay
well so much of the phone [ __ ] I realize
I am creating all of the texting that
I'm doing like I'm in traffic traffic
sucks I just start calling people right
just like hey man what's going on I
literally have a friend of mine that we
like we are friendship because she's
married with kids I'm married and have a
kid and it's just like our whole
relationship I don't think I've seen her
in a year and a half our relationship
that we have the deal the unwritten deal
is that we call each other when we're
stuck in traffic
yeah then the big joke is a I'm on the
134 and that's in or the other person
picks up alright where are you how long
a drive do you have and it's just like
you're sort of almost like a suicide
hotline I'm getting them to get home I
do like all of my phone calls in the car
too or really really late at night like
while I'm getting ready for bed like
like my friends in Australia just know
that I'm gonna call like 3:00 a.m. my
time like facetiming them well I'm like
brushing my teeth and [ __ ] now it's like
a ritual like oh we ready for teeth
brushing time and what is it like seven
the next day they're right 7:00 at night
fortunately or even slightly yeah
something like that yeah right around
about then it's great that guy I always
call Australia at that time when I'm
getting ready for bed time when was the
last time you heard some music that made
you like whenever I listen to like
amazing music I always fantasize that
it's me doing it oh yeah yeah I do that
run all the way through the song if the
drums are awesome I'm playing drums
someone's singing great then all of a
sudden I'm doing that I'm very
self-involved when was the last time you
as a musician listened to something and
you were just like oh [ __ ] I wish that
was me does that happen
alright no it doesn't happen but strike
two with the texting and now you're
fantasizing I don't do that but I listen
and admire a lot of people who'd you to
listen to coming up I didn't want to ask
you any of these questions I know you've
been asked this man okay listen to
Miles Davis and then of course there was
the Bee Gees jazz disco I just really
obsessed with is Indian classical music
do you remember that time we were like
driving back from one of your shows and
I played you some Indian Indian
classical music Bob Dylan song to you
which you really didn't like or you were
making fun of but Bob Dylan is like one
of my favorites of all time I love Bob
Dylan okay but like you were like
jerking around like changing the lyrics
and stuff I was just being an [ __ ] we
do that all the time you made me laugh
so much and then I played you an Indian
classical piece but maybe you don't
remember that but what I remember you
played me that blues song yeah that was
Blind Willie Johnson yes also one of my
fav yes okay yeah dad I remember yeah I
love old blues like it's so raw and real
right and I also like like because if
you you'll notice like on my album like
I switch in and out of like time
signatures a lot and but it doesn't
sound like I'm switching time CP inches
at least that's what I do that on that's
the things that I yeah I didn't really
notice that that's what I'm saying like
because I kind of I let the music like
the melody or the story guide the time
as opposed to like the other way around
like sometimes people will write the
music first and then that lay the melody
and stuff on top I saw an interview with
somebody said that said every time I
come on with the riff it's in a weird
time signature and then the drummer
fixes it I remember thinking like he
should have [ __ ] kept it right
getting that yeah but like why not what
I'm just saying that so that's what I
that's what I would think yeah I was
joking around like with with Bob Weir
because like basically he played with
lightning Hopkins medium bob weird yeah
mm-hmm Grateful Dead right he played
with lightnin Hopkins who's one of my
favorite like blues players and I know
when he started like those guys were all
like in their 40s right
yeah and blues guys I mean and and he
was joking around like saying that like
lighten and played like the 12 and a
half ba blues because you know if he has
to add a beat to finish the the story
he's telling there's gonna add a beat
like it's not about like just this rigid
thing and like
I was I've been composing like that too
like if the melody wants to go on a few
beats longer or you know then make it a
bar or seven like and it will feel
natural if if it goes with the melody
but if you try to fit a melody over the
top of the time signature then sometimes
it can feel a little bit more choppy
yeah I get that yeah because then it's
that because to the layperson they're
not listening what time it's in know the
melody and the story is old folk music
to like you listen to some old folk like
you hear like Baz five and seven because
they're just adding beats to like finish
the phrase yeah I know I never noticed
and that sometimes why like you know
that there won't be drums on it like if
there was drums it probably would sound
kind of strange but it's just like an
acoustic guitar and a voice like that
song I played for you that Bob Dylan
song that's called it's a right mom and
he bleeding like there's some buzz of
like five and [ __ ] and that he just like
adds some beats and as you wouldn't you
wouldn't know it but if you counted it
it's odd because he's just trying to fit
the lyric in oh yeah it's it's genius I
love it man you're so talented in that
area like one when did when do you
notice that [ __ ] like I would just be
like I'm just psyched if I listen to a
song I know all the words oh that was
just in seven when I first like moved to
America and I was playing guitar I and I
was like starting to play like six hours
a day and I like gave myself tendinitis
and I had to stop playing for a minute
and then I started like like messing
around like with drums with one hand or
like bass with one hand and people
started coming up to me being like yeah
mini Vinny Vinny Vinny and I'm like what
the [ __ ] is mini Vinny like you know
Vinnie Colaiuta okay so I went and like
listened to Vinnie Colaiuta this was me
at I guess like 17 now and and everyone
was passing around tapes of Vinnie
Colaiuta like whoa like the stuff with
charisma and stuff and and actually
Vinnie was then one of the first people
I met when when I moved to America
because he came to my school and I'd
been playing for two and a half months
at the time and like one of the these
drum clinicians was
with him wait a minute you don't even
play in two and a half months and
somebody told you to move to a space
because I've been playing it for a
couple years
yeah yeah right what was that like and
he was like oh we should play sometime I
said yeah and I was so shy like because
I'd listened to all this stuff and
obviously he's he's one of the best in
the world and I was but I kept it in my
head I'm like okay okay but then I moved
to New York and I'm like I just want to
be a jazz musician I want to like play
in clubs like five times a night and
like Charlie Parker and monk and all the
guys did right and and I did that for a
few years and then that's when I like I
played with the Allman Brothers and like
made a record played with the Allman
Brothers that was my first gig when I
was a teenager Jesus Christ yeah like
that's where it all started and then I
came back to LA and I like played
Vanitas stuff with the OMA brothers in
my my solo project and and then the
weeks later he got the call from Jeff
Beck that like or hit Jeff Beck's
management that they needed a bass
player and then he he told them about me
and then they called me and they asked
me to send in tapes I sent in the tapes
and the next thing I knew I was flying
to England to audition for Jeff so and
then everything like you know Prince and
her how are you I think I was 21 when I
started playing with Jeff yeah Jesus
Christ that's the first time I saw you
we're talking that live at Ronnie
Scott's which I've still never been in
there the couple times I've gone to
London I already see it it's always like
packed a mic I'll [ __ ] want to go in
there and just yeah have a drink and
actually listen to some music for like
two so that's the first time I saw you
so were you nervous when you went into
the audition well I was food poisoned I
just got enough a plane like where me
and Vinny went to the airport and I ate
some barbecue chicken pizza and I got on
the plane and Vinny's like raving on
about politics because he's obsessed
with politics and I'm like eh Vinny I'm
feeling kind of sick and he's like yeah
yeah so then this happened and not he
yeah I mean he kind of reminds me of you
and you remind me of him I thought he
was from he's from like Pennsylvania
Oh is he yeah
yeah Pittsburgh always some Pittsburgh
yeah it's a Pittsburgh guy oh he went to
Berkeley that's why I knew it was some
sort of Massachusetts right okay but
anyway he's going on about politics and
then meanwhile I just like throw up in a
bag and like there it is you think that
what is I'm like I'll see you in ten
hours and I was so sick that like then I
had to like get rushed to the hospital
when we landed and like be on a trip and
then the next day I auditioned for Jeff
and so I was feeling really weird but
talk about the worst [ __ ] place to
give food poisoning my god but the
audition went well because at that point
I was so like woozy that I was just like
okay let's get through this
yeah and and then that was the point
where like Jeff pointed to me and said
so low on cause we've ended his lovers
and like he ended up loving that so much
that he like kept it in the set and
that's how he was like featuring me
every night oh wow which is so like cool
of him
considering who he is and all of that
stuff to like I love when people do
stuff like that there's a lot of
comedians that I you know that I'm a fan
of but what really makes me you know
over the top is when I see them like
encouraging and helping out you know
comics that are coming up because I hate
that [ __ ] thing of you know that
behavior people get to a certain level
then they start treating you know and
I'm here and you're there it's all
stupid it's just like it's you know
you're great like that like the way that
you kind of mentor younger comedians I
mean I try not to be in it I mean I
remember most people were nice but I
definitely member want people who
weren't not necessarily the names but I
just remember how that made me feel so
it's it's sort of the same thing to with
being like a parent and stuff I remember
the good days at school and I remember
the bad day so I don't know how much fun
it was playing with the other kids at
school and then I also remember how bad
it was if you know you wore the wrong
shirt or whatever it's just it was just
your day to take the pounding and just
like how you could just literally
beginning you know it's literally like
your world and that's something that I'm
hoping I'm gonna be able to remember
which I think I will is my kids going
through school as far as knowing that
though I mean those days I mean who the
hell knows
with all the [ __ ] cameras out there I
don't like anything my buddy was just
telling me you know some he told this
story there was some kid everybody
picked on that day and then the kids who
picked on him they found out who all of
them were and they had to go see the
[ __ ] psychologist and [ __ ] and I was
really thinking about that's the cycle I
mean like nobody like there was none of
that at all mmm-hmm like the guidance
counselor was just some weirdo down the
hall and he would just he just would
talk to he would only really talk to
kids who had no hope of going to college
right
and he just be down there like well hey
man you know like maybe you get into
construction you know I mean I never
even talked to you I just I don't know
what he talked to him about maybe they
have home lives and [ __ ] maybe was like
a therapy thing but like only the [ __ ]
up kids got guidance right everybody
else was just like all right you're
following the cattle right over the
[ __ ] cliff go to school two years of
language get into college pick a major
decide what the [ __ ] you want to do at
18 and then hit yeah it was one of those
things and um I remember when I was 15
there was like this like woman that came
to the school that was supposedly like a
career counselor Oh God and she came
with this huge book that looked like
yellow pages or something right and
everyone had to have an appointment and
and you'd go in and she'd be like okay
so now what do you want to do and like
someone be like I want to be a doctor
and so I walked in she's like so what do
you want to do like that wouldn't be a
musician and she's like sorry there's no
musician here what what else would you
like to do I just walked out oh you
walked out what did she do I don't know
that's it I would have but yeah I would
have had like an epiphany being like wow
I mean how many of these [ __ ] kids
wanted to do something that's not in
this book right yeah but then you have
to look at earth just like there's no
way that was her dream in life they have
a yellow book and talk to people half
your age what do you want to do I want
to be
keeper all right let's get to disease
all right you have any khaki shorts so
you literally have somebody who didn't
follow a dream talking you out of yours
and you had the strength to [ __ ] walk
away from that that's very very
commendable so that's that those are the
moments in life that haunt me that I
think that into my life when somebody
said something negative and thank God
you know I I didn't latch onto it
totally in somebody else like cuz I I
have like I have like there's like three
mic moments in my life you know
like climbing up a [ __ ] cliff that if
I went to go this way I would have fell
back down and and just the luck of it
sometimes when I think of it like god
what if I didn't meet this person you
know and why anyway I've worked with
this guy in a warehouse and I finally
found somebody that was into comedy the
way I was and he understood that you
could become it you know what I mean
like he was going like dude these guys
on TV and not funny man one of these
days I'm gonna take a shot at Jack
Daniels and just go on stage and do it
and all of a sudden like cuz it just you
know it was on TV that was like a
million miles away there was no [ __ ]
internet or anything and we had nobody
had video cameras nothing so it just
seemed impossible it didn't even seem
impossible didn't even I didn't even
enter my brain be like [ __ ] going in
the moon and all of a sudden he was just
next to me going I'm gonna [ __ ] do it
and I was just thinking like well [ __ ]
if he can try it I'm gonna try it
so if I don't run into him and if he
doesn't have the balls to say I'm gonna
try it then I'm just [ __ ] hanging out
with other knuckleheads like me drinking
then then all of a sudden I'm 30 and
where the [ __ ] am I you know so but do
you believe like in like a destiny like
you believe that if that wouldn't have
happened someone else would have
happened or do you believe like it I
don't believe in destiny because of
tragedy right I don't think that
anybody's destiny is there the hey thank
god you're not this person I just think
you get lucky you get lucky it's it's
like a half-court shot I would say in a
lot of wait well maybe it's not that
it's it's do you think it's like partly
luck and partly men of
stationed like if you really want
something you're gonna create the path
for it and it can and it can go in many
directions yeah but I also feel like and
there's also tragedy which is yeah
unavoidable and unpredictable the
tragedy of where you're born right what
you look like what race you are what
part of the world you're in like how
lucky I was to be a white guy born in
USA you know what I mean and how lucky I
was to be born outside of Boston had
this crazy insane scene there's like a
lot of like you know hurdles that were
like this big fan even then even then
because of all the [ __ ] that even
does even if you get that much of a head
start all of this other [ __ ] that can
emotionally [ __ ] you up can you know I
mean I think by the time I was like nine
I had already just sort of like I had
that yeah I don't give a [ __ ] I don't
give a [ __ ] I don't yeah I just didn't
give a [ __ ] like anybody and and but I
did you know what I mean and then that's
all your work to get back to that person
who did care and did want stuff you just
as a defense mechanism you just like I
don't give a [ __ ] oh really is that
gonna happen no and then then one of
that's supposed to what make me cry
[ __ ] you like I became that person which
is it's it works as far as to get
through that [ __ ] but as far as getting
anything that you [ __ ] want in life
we have to be open and warm and in a
track stuff to you that you want and
you're over there with you oh yeah I
don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] you really four
hundred pounds in my chest put five
hundred I don't give a [ __ ] doing that
dumb guys [ __ ] yeah there's like yeah
it's just yeah that's that that's the
thing when you're sitting there and it
[ __ ] Boston Garden going how to [ __ ]
if I didn't meet this guy if that guy
didn't say that if I went out that night
went with those people and did that you
just think of all of that [ __ ] what
if [ __ ] and there's somebody who went
out that night went with those people
and then they [ __ ] sitting in a
cubicle or a jail cell or in a [ __ ]
loveless marriage or something and then
just
like wine if that that's somebody's
destiny to be in a loveless marriage
it's like I just I don't
yeah and Karma's another one I don't buy
into
I think karma works if you if you
believe in it
what do you how do you define kama that
basically if you're a good person good
things happen to you but if you're bad
person no that's not what kama is though
but in my world it is but comment if you
like kama simply means cause and effect
so okay well if you do good things then
no it's not about good or bad you feel
like I'm in school you know no but you
do it you don't you just give me the F
and all those summer school like you you
you do an action and it causes a result
right it's as simple as that
that's all kama means it's like getting
a Satanist people thinks that you
believe in the devil and people really
just like Satanism or whatever they
don't even believe in a heaven or hell
or a devil right it's just they just
living for themselves and everybody's oh
they're into the devil so I always
thought combos like if you're [ __ ]
this hole then bad [ __ ] happens to you
and I know in my business I'd watch
these [ __ ] people stealing and doing
all this [ __ ] and just look at them and
be like well you know good you know
nothing's Bad's happening them and I've
done a bunch of bad [ __ ] and like over
all my life is good but I you know I've
heard a lot of people and [ __ ] so no and
it just it just simply means that you do
an action and it creates a result so all
these people are using that term
incorrectly yes I just put it in a
script incorrectly f is for family
well it's correct in that because like a
lot of people think that's what it what
it is but like when you go to the roots
of what comma is it just simply means
like you do an action that's cause and
effect I saw somebody somebody follow an
Instagram they had a picture of a
boomerang and it said karma on it so
that's actually wrong oh my god I wish I
knew the real definition then I could
have been that pompous ass on the
internet being like actually none of you
guys that's like one time I saw this guy
talking about how he didn't have white
privilege and his idea that he didn't
have white privilege
because he wasn't born rich and he had
to work for the things that he had so
his idea is that white privilege just
means you're born on a yacht and all of
this [ __ ] [ __ ] it's like no that's
not what that means that means at no
point will you with because of your
seating just get pulled over for being
white get this [ __ ] kicked out of you
you know and and all of these other
things that would have happened to you
you just you basically because you had
to work for things you feel you're not
privileged so literally his definition
was privilege I always give you any more
details of it I'll tell you afterwards
all right how do you how do you deal
with like um internet troll II type
people like have you ever struggled with
that or wanted to interact with people
like that
early on I did but not it has nothing to
do with me yeah yeah it has nothing to
do the amount of [ __ ] that I hate that
really just has to do with me and my day
right that I do and other people do that
- I don't think um you know any
different than they are but like yeah I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't have to be a
specific thing that I did and I thought
it was bad - and then everybody said you
shouldn't have done that blah blah blah
I don't think I don't know what but if
it's just like you know you know so much
of whatever you post isn't about what
you posted it's about what's in the
background oh my god that's [ __ ]
great but what's up with that [ __ ]
picture on the wall laughing my ass off
like that's like but what I learned
after a while is like that's their
moment right on the thread right like
I'm gonna be the guy that notices the
thing that starts and then everybody's
talking about what I wanted to talk
about and then it's just a weird thing
where you feel good but like I I I do
the same thing if I send out a tweet and
it gets a bunch of retweets and like
sigh my god people thought that was
funny so I'm just on the other end of it
so I just learned like I can't get upset
that somebody is noticing something in
this and now they're doing that little
show like who the [ __ ] am I it's like
you don't want so I'm going to do that
don't post something on there and I just
look at like listen you don't want
people saying a bunch of bad [ __ ] about
you don't put your face on the Internet
it's like you're literally asking for it
you're sticking your chin out yeah and
they're winding up and punching you and
then you're acting like
victim it's like well you [ __ ] don't
post [ __ ] just sit there like this or
you know post it take a few shots and
continue on I guess as a musician like I
will firstly like as an instrumental
musician there's nothing anybody can say
about like what I'm saying I'm not
expressing an opinion I'm just playing
notes right but then now I've just put
out an album of songs with lyrics and
there's only been three alright
no what I'm saying is that in the
context of the song and I'm very much
expressing like stories that are
personal but like to go out there as a
comedian and like express really strong
opinions like I can't imagine like the
difference in like the kind of feedback
that you get and what people do is you
have to understand that what they do is
they don't like I've always said it's
like you can do 80 jokes in a row and
someone will sit there laughing and
enjoying your set and then the 80 first
one has to do something about them it's
a fat joke and they're fat right if it's
about women and they're a woman or it's
about this state and they're from there
and then all of a sudden yeah it's funny
is think that then they go that
statement you made about Arkansas and
it's just like no no they were also they
are all jokes except for the one right
you don't mean so there's this this that
you know there's just that that thing I
just II I don't pay it any mind and yep
there was ever any sort of big dust-up
about something I said if I actually
looked at and thought I said something
wrong I'd be like I well maybe I'll
phrase it a different way but like I I
do think it's absolutely ridiculous that
people get offended about a joke that
was told at a show that they weren't at
this is taken so out of context and you
know you wanted to show yeah and you
chose to click on that thing and the
tears another thing - if the comedian
didn't film it and post it yeah if just
some [ __ ] [ __ ] in the crowd did
get mad at them yeah and it's just like
well what the [ __ ] are you doing if
you're this easily offended about
stand-up comedy what are you doing
watching watching stand-up comedy the
whole thing is so like I just saw I
think was in Australia like the first
mammal when
stinks due to glue fumin global warming
and barely barely a word about it but
like all of this [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
you know it's more difficult to be a
comedian if you're a woman [ __ ] me
too it's all about us and what we're
going through and blah blah blah blah
and all of this [ __ ] and just meanwhile
all of that pales in comparison to you
know if this [ __ ] place is in here
you're not gonna have to worry about any
of that right that's why I think that
the cellphones are super destructive
like because they are making everything
about me me me look what I'm doing look
like where I am
look what I'm eating it so and and we're
on it constantly and it's like whoa did
you see Chris D'Elia Eufaula did you see
his thing that he did the the
unfollowing No oh my god it's one of my
favorite things ever he's talking about
just making fun of Instagram models I
mean I can do it I don't feel like I'm
doing this joke because he put it out
there he goes look he goes if you're on
Instagram it goes and your posts and
stuff you're just taking a picture of
your booty and your titties he goes make
no mistake you hook it and he just
starts calling them hookers and and you
know and then he just starts really like
something some of these people I don't
even know [ __ ] exist it I guess this
thing that pretty girls do with a bite
into a sandwich and they kind of look up
like that right saying like yeah yeah
that I'm gonna start this thing called
the unfollowing and what I love about it
is first of all I'm seeing him turning
the corner as a comedian cuz he was
always just he just had that this guy is
a like a [ __ ] closer you know and now
he's getting he's like fine in his like
like this razor because he was always
kind of fun and energetic and stuff and
but now it's it's like it's like it's
becoming this you seeing this force
going in this direction like I was
[ __ ] cry and laugh like nighttime
nothing very few things along those
lines make me laugh and it's just really
[ __ ] was making me laugh but the
funniest thing about that is that would
really bother somebody like that we're
like yes because they're living
not that I would want to hurt those
people because it's very easy to hate
beautiful people you know what I mean it
just is they're very hateable as you're
staring at them because you hate
yourself like why am i this [ __ ]
obsessed with like this beauty and all
of this stuff like look at you got like
I gotta [ __ ] through nine hours of
[ __ ] specials to get half as many
followings as you do because you wore a
[ __ ] half shirt you know so I just
there was just something funny to just
finally see a movement to make their
numbers go down I don't know the more
I'm saying this out loud I'm actually
realizing that it's kind of says more
about me than about those people that
take those pictures but it's I don't
know I just thought it was it that [ __ ]
is funny so I'm actually watching that
girl at the gas station I'm gonna try to
take like this morning I didn't have my
phone you know when I spent the entire
like two and a half hours ahead with my
daughter this morning chased her around
we play with the puzzles I read the
books what else did we do was teach her
how to play catch and I think she's
gonna throw at the left hand which would
be really cool although she's really big
with the Darryl Dawkins over-the-top
sort of two-handed slam I know you're
not gonna know that reference you play
for the 76ers before you were born so
I'm trying to get her not to be into
stuff like that but the weird thing is
is because they're so hyper with their
energy and all you want to do is just
hold them and hug them the best way to
do that is if you put on their favorite
cartoon and then they just totally
snuggle up next to but then there's no
interaction other than the physical
because then you just you're literally
saying like hey hey hey you know give me
a kiss give me a kiss and they'll go
like I'll just sort of lean into you and
not even look at you just give you the
cheek and they just sort of lasered into
that and I'm like I don't know I watched
a lot of TV I did all right in life the
[ __ ] you're gonna do it allowed to watch
TV and look at you a [ __ ] talented or
and I'm up there just screaming yelling
like a lunatic where can people get this
album anyway yeah listen to music can
they download it on iTunes
yeah Spotify
I don't think it sure thing's gonna be
set up on this podcast than that yeah I
can't cuz my [ __ ] computer's filled
up and I forget my password all the time
well I just want to congratulate you
because I know you've worked so hard on
this yeah it's just assembling a band
and all of that type of stuff like
there's so much more work to this where
I just like I need to know write a new
hour I don't have to find a mic stand
guy and all of this [ __ ] I just have to
go out and just go do it but whatever
you did the three songs that I listen to
I mean it is just it's on such a high
level creativity and everything I'm
really happy for you and everybody
watching listening because there are is
gonna be some clips of this on video
please download and it is called love
remain love remains alright thank you
for coming on I was gonna ask you how do
you stop doing ohms and Oz and your nose
and [ __ ] like that how do i ya know I
don't I do it all just do it all the
time why cuz I get something no cuz you
do it I do it so much oh I do it too
oh you do and you don't care no no I
don't give a [ __ ] do you listen to uh
Keith Richards TMJ people can't
understand him he doesn't give a [ __ ]
but like what about when you're doing
material I guess because you've written
the material that's gonna be less of
that because you know what you're about
to say as opposed to if you're just
doing a podcast if I was actually trying
to work on something like that then I
would be up here which is not where I
wanted right yeah I want to be it's just
coming down the rain spout and out my
[ __ ] would that be like considered
technique for a comedian to like at some
point work on that yes it would
where is like with like I learned when I
started taken from lessons from Davey
Lich
how many like how much you know of the
way I was playing was getting in the way
of me getting to where I wanted to be
with whatever because my my technique I
was like sitting like this and I was
grabbing the sticks like that was
getting blisters and and I like I wasn't
making gravity anything
had to do with physics work for me so I
was literally fighting the drumkit and
then he taught me all of this stuff I've
seen him in a couple of months and I'm
going back to my bad old habits but
there is that thing I think that like Y
will say with like a musician it's like
I want to learn how to read man I just
want to you know I just want to [ __ ]
be this you know free [ __ ] thing
right and just there is merit in that
because you do have those people who
only can play if there's sheet music in
front of them but if you can somehow
marry both of those where you actually
have technique but you can still play
from here yeah and not be up there I
think that that's like the promised land
and I always kind of felt is a comedian
if you could somehow combine Richard
Pryor that specially did live in concert
on Long Beach if you could combine that
with George Carlin where his stuff was
just like I feel like he knew every
[ __ ] word that he was going to say
and it was like yeah just like up up up
up up up up the whole time where Pryor
you know on that special came walking
out it was like a hell gig there was
people walking around and [ __ ] and he
just started making fun of people and I
think the way he was wired that helped
him that helped him better than if
everyone was just sitting there staring
at him like okay begin your your
stand-up special I think that he came
out and you know sit yo ass down you
know sit your [ __ ] ugly ass down what
all that stuff that he was saying and
everyone's just walking around he's
riffing and then he just just got in a
zone and what's amazing you know is he
began to his own usually that'll last
for like six minutes because what
happens up to six minutes of that is
you're like you'd start worrying going
what happens when this ends and I have
to go into my act I'm gonna be [ __ ]
and you you can't think that because
that it's almost like when you ever try
like meditating yeah yeah so you know
like when you start to feel like you're
floating and like leaving your body if
you start thinking oh my god this is
great
Ilia and then you
right back down so that's the same way
with like like catching a stone so like
what I've learned a little I know about
technique with like drums is you just
practice a little bit every day and then
when it starts to become this thing you
don't have to think about then all those
skills you learned about sort of leaving
your body and just like just like I mean
your body's there but you're you're
listening to what you're playing that's
making you do that next thing if you can
exist you can go back there with all
this technique now you're not gonna get
hurt you're not gonna get tired I'm
eventually will but like so I think what
the comedian if if I was to try to do
that like okay maybe I won't curse as
much or something like that
like I that would definitely be a few
steps backwards by that man maybe it
would help me I don't know I I don't
think I don't think okay cuz if I go up
there and I start doing that it's all
about not being here um I mean I said
I'm obviously thinking like okay I'm
gonna it's more like okay you okay just
walk out I just start talking and then
this joke comes out and then I said this
joke which made me think oh yeah I have
this joke and look at this [ __ ] guy
and then it just sort of just oh now
we're over here and just you just do you
have a like a set list of jokes like you
want to do it in this order or this
order
yeah but that is all out the [ __ ]
window the second I go up there oh yeah
and so well some nights it goes like
that
and then other nights like I definitely
have like sections but this some nights
I just go out there and all of a sudden
I tell the last joke first and I'm
switching everything around and then the
guy I taught it to go on stage going
like dude I don't know what the [ __ ] was
going on oh you did you close a bit in
the middle is like way he's only doing
35 minutes and then you went on you did
like another you know whatever another
25 after that or something
I have like the main setlist you know so
that's the you know this is the plan the
general [ __ ] plan and then go out
there and [ __ ] happens you're in a weird
mood some
he says something's you look at
something in the back of the room that
makes you think of something and then it
go it goes in that direction
and and I am a full believer of doing
that because then it doesn't become this
grind because I used to I used to have I
start with this and then that leads to
this and I have my Segway zip up right
and it just became like you know it's
rigid yeah and then I would be on stage
and my mouth would be talking and I
would find myself thinking about going
like well the second show if the
headliner lets me not close it out I
could probably be home by and then I was
just like yeah and then I'll say like
wait I'm talking right now and people
are laughing and I'm thinking about
other [ __ ] what the [ __ ] am i doing
right now and I uh
it's weird I learned how to free myself
up through why more through watching
musicians I've always equated it to
music because that's something that I
sort of started with so I always thought
I remember talking to a long time ago
late great Patrice O'Neal and I said I
was telling him I was like you know I
always wish I could see somebody cuz I
couldn't gauge how good you were you
know you can't see how good you are how
much you're improving cuz you're you you
know what I mean you're just in there so
I always said I always wanted to I wish
I could just have somebody sit down and
play guitar at the level of comic that I
am right now it's like could they change
chords could they play without looking
could they solo like where am I on that
trajectory it's one of the few times he
didn't give me any [ __ ] he was just like
honey cuz that's actually interesting
then probably I reacted to that and then
he probably trashed me because he
actually opened up for half a second so
yeah fascinating fascinating nuts and
bolts of how to tell dick and [ __ ] jokes
will continue after these messages from
stamps calm and now for a bill buzz
theme song oh I get a theme song out of
this I would have thought it would have
been on like a ukulele some sort of
Irish jig song do they play ukuleles out
there I don't know you have to play
though seriously I have to play yeah why
do I have to because I'm gonna sing your
theme song
then you have to tell a joke I have to
tell a joke well why do I have to do my
hobby do you know what I mean what am i
playing do crack I don't have any your
[ __ ] jump okay so to play it really
softly play it really softly is that
pianoforte hey could you just can you
just just make sure you do the [ __ ]
huh the [ __ ] yeah I learned how we're
gonna [ __ ] in the end all right yeah
[Music]
that's all I get no no no one's gonna
keep oh I didn't know okay you don't
[ __ ] like this is so simple
yeah let me see what if you add
yes I'll be like welcome to Bill best
Monday morning podcast on a Thursday
afternoon welcome to build buzz Monday
morning podcast on a Thursday afternoon
yeah I can't be like it's like it's like
triple is like how your brain works my
brain doesn't do that occasionally don't
do that but not really
[Music]
that's how Destin that's the [ __ ]
[Applause]
like a soldier
between
[Music]
he's
but I
[Music]